(makes bird call)
- Don't go anywhere.
- [Voiceover] Being in a
bald eagle nest is surreal.
This is a wild animal.
- She's being rowdy.
- [Voiceover] It's very
capable of hurting you
if you're not careful,
so you have to take your time.
- A little rough, huh? Sorry about that.
- [Voiceover] It's an experience
that's hard to describe.
- My name is Jim Campbell-Spickler.
I'm a forest canopy ecologist
and a wildlife biologist.
And I'm pretty sure I have
the best job in the world.
(birds tweeting)
- [Voiceover] My job is to
climb into the eagle's nest
and capture and work with chicks.
- Yeah, he's a monster.
- [Voiceover] And the reason
why we're doing this is,
we're trying to get blood samples.
and we can use those blood samples
to look at environmental contaminants
and how they get into the
bald eagles' food source.
- Gonna make me chase ya, huh?
Why don't you come off there. Come down.
- [Voiceover] It's a challenging
species to work with.
It's got a really sharp, hooked beak.
And its talons are big and powerful.
And you don't wanna let
him grab ahold of you,
because they can really do some damage.
- Alright. Let's go down.
- [Voiceover] This is a wild animal
so you never know what could happen.
(gasps and groans)
The Channel Islands are an island chain
off the coast of Southern California.
- These two guys don't look too bad.
- [Voiceover] They're
a desert island system.
You get out there and you can
stand on top of these bluffs
and you can see the Pacific.
A whole 360-degree view
of just the most beautiful
ocean you can ever imagine.
You've got not only bald eagles,
you have peregrine falcons
that are nesting on the sea cliffs.
- Just tell me if she's comin' in.
(grunts)
- [Voiceover] You've got a
host of different sea birds.
And it's just a magical place.
Our research, it may
look invasive, but really,
one of our primary concerns is the safety
of these young birds that we're handling,
so we go to great lengths
to ensure that we don't injure them
and that when we put
them back in the nest,
they're just as well-off
as when we first encountered them.
- He likes you.
- [Woman] Oh, hi!
- The bald eagle's our national bird
so it's quite an honor for me
to get to work with this species.
Quite often I'll just sit
in that nest for a moment
and just take in the view
and just think, "wow," you know,
It's just an honor to get up there,
be able to share that view
and that experience with them
just for that moment in time.